the presidential campaigns will soon
move beyond convention halls like this
one and shift into all-out general
election mode political cartoonists will
document every step and misstep of the
race you could say Barack is surrounded
this morning by satirical art at a
gallery right here in good old Cleveland
Ohio Moe good morning good morning you'd
have to go back several cycles to find a
campaign so right for the fine art of
political satire whether it's Donald
Trump's hair or Hillary Clinton's pants
suits for political cartoonists this is
a boom time at the Cleveland art gallery
spaces there's the Reagan for decades of
political cartoons from former
syndicated editorial artist ed fresca
are now on display what makes for a
successful political cartoon when I have
provoked somebody into thinking I don't
know it's left-right doesn't matter
American political art predates the
founding of this country Benjamin
Franklin did that famous cartoon of the
snake that's cut up to the 13 colonies
which if they don't unite are not going
to survive Henry Adams is an art
historian and a descendent of presidents
John Adams and John Quincy Adams the
great political cartoonists of the past
would would this be great material for
them right now do you think oh I think
that this is a year that's made for a
political cartoonist Donald Trump is
just a cartoonist dream just his hair
his face in the way he speaks you know
there's a cartoon quality to that they
could draw him every day
David horsey is a two-time Pulitzer
Prize winning editorial cartoonist with
the LA Times he's wielding his pen all
this week in Cleveland I've drawn him as
King Kong I've drawn him as a barbarian
conquering Rome I've drawn him as sort
of a caveman there are wonderful ways
you can analogies you can find for his
sort of macho I'm in charge I don't care
style political cartooning isn't just
about
caricaturing an individual caricaturing
is just one of the tools i mean really
it's it's I'm providing commentary like
you know a columnist would and I think
the drawing adds something sort of a
heightened reality horseys politics are
liberal even so when you're looking at
Hillary Clinton which physical features
are our good material for political
cartoonist well you start with the face
she has a very kind of round faith
moonface
kind of a small mouth big eyes they're
sort of a I don't know I'm gonna get in
trouble with this but kind of this
Midwestern mom what to her it may sound
a bit harsh but the point is to draw
blood right here we have a Nixon with
this patented little receding hairline
Richard Nixon gave the cartoonists of
his era plenty of material I think that
Nixon was a kind of sneaky looking guy
and it wasn't too hard to exaggerate the
whole tradition of political cartooning
has been to to poke fun at the powerful
and humor itself is is very seldom nice
right I mean it's you're always finding
the weakness and going after that and
that's ultimately the job of a political
cartoon cartoonist is just to
intelligently provoke with with images
and observations about the world and
maybe just maybe move the masses and you
may be overly humbly say that it rarely
moves the needle and in turns an
election but Abraham Lincoln thank
Thomas Nast for the 1864 reelection
yeah and then and then ulysses s grant I
think credited Thomas Nast also I don't
think I've changed minds but I've
marshaled forces the best ones somehow
they can take an issue that you don't
care about and they can make it seem
very immediate and visceral where are
they on the scale of effectiveness right
now I think this is a period where no
one quite knows what's going on I think
that social media have
had a big impact we're communicating
with word and image in other words the
meme has given millions of social media
users a political say this may indeed be
a golden age of political yes I think it
probably will be ago it probably in some
way that we can't quite anticipate okay
so II D fresca retired a few years ago
but this is something he drew for his
own amusement and for ours this is a
cartoon about the recent flap between
Supreme Court Justice Ruth Bader
Ginsburg and Donald Trump it's pretty
funny up very well done yeah